- I actually took my family to Disneyland
recently too, my kiddos.
How was your?
Did you have any meltdowns?
I didn't have one meltdown.
- No, me neither.
- Rare.
- Very rare.
- And it was,
(audience cheering)
it was raining the whole time,
but we were just like,
"We can think about the rain
or we can think about Disneyland."
And we chose the latter
and it was awesome.
It was also really special because
my "Frozen" cast got inducted into,
"Oh, that's my husband."
- Y'all are adorable.
(audience laughing)
- I like him.
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm keeping him.
- My "Frozen" cast and I,
got inducted into the
Disney Legend ceremony,
(audience cheering)
so we were.
- What does that entail?
- I don't know,
but all I.
- That's exciting.
- You get a pin.
- Okay.
- And apparently
the pin is a very big deal,
and I don't know what it gets me yet.
- Yeah.
- All I'm really wondering
is if it will get me into Club 33.
- I keep hearing about this, yeah,
this random club, yes.
That like.
- Random club?
- [Kelly] Wait, no,
it's random if you don't know.
I don't know.
- That's true.
So it's like super exclusive.
You gotta pay like dues to it,
which I'm not gonna do,
(everyone laughs)
but I'm gonna
walk to the front and go.
- [Kelly] With my pin,
with my legend.
- With my little pin.
Apparently it's like,
yeah, you pay yearly,
and then it's a super
fancy, beautiful restaurant
in the middle of Disney
that you can go eat.
And I also think it's the only
place that serves alcohol.
- Oh?
- In Disney.
- Okay.
- See, alcohol.
(audience clapping)
- I don't know if that's
my kinda vibe either.
I have kids, they don't
do so great in fancy.
- [Kristen] Yeah, don't bring your kids
to Club 33.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- But put them at.
- I just mean
if you're going there.
- Ariel's Grotto, and then
you can go to Club 33.
- And that's where we go.
(Kelly laughing)
(Kelly clapping)
- Yeah, of course.
- That's where we have to go.
I'm like, I don't think
I wanna bring my children
in that environment
for other people's sake.
(Kristen chuckles)